[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien c'est tout le monde sait squeeze
on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour le 3ème
au 4ème épisode je me souviens même plus
sur ce fameux oh toi tu te calmes tu me
laisses par les faire la présentation
d'avant de la vidéo hockey / dong dead
island est alors aujourd'hui les gens
j'ai souffert comme jamais j'ai souffert
alors écoutez on va avancer en même
temps et je vais vous raconter ce qui
s'est passé ce matin c'était mais alors
mais quand je vous dis que vous avez
déjà passé une matinée affreuse laisser
dans vos commentaires les trucs les plus
affreux qui vous soit arrivé à côté moi
ce qui va arriver c'est forcément pire
je vais vous expliquer alors en gros
donc je me lève donc tu as ta tâche
commence à 10h j'ai deux heures de ps je
me lève je suis lâché ouais super une
journée de cours on va se faire chier ou
alors j'y vais et où donc en fait je
voulais y aller en vélo
sauf que j'avais pas d'antivol donc jean
- sms cng z
celui qui fait des défis avec moi
antoine également jay z égale n'aiguise
ok c'est bon tout le monde se souvient
parfait donc je vais m'en sms du dit
ouais écoute
gg je vais amener mon vélo mais j'ai pas
dedans tu vois le est-ce que tu tues tu
peux me prêter
toi tu vois les touches pastel chez toi
y comme ça et tout est au final baquet
attendait pourquoi j'ai pas d'armes
c'est pas ça qui passa dans la cas ça me
dit ah ouais super je vais y aller même
prêté son antivol super j'en ai gagné
vingt mille ans parce que je ne serai
pas casser qu à descendre puisque le
lycée il est à 25 minutes de chez moi à
pied et je me dis ouais trop coup je me
serais papeete qu à y aller à pied un
lol génial super et du coup j'y vais j'y
arrive démons chaîne dz fait ouais jay z
[ __ ] mais comment je change d'âme je
sais plus à allah parfait et du coup je
dis j'ai déjà aidé on chez lui je fais
scud moi s'il te plaît antivol merci
boom faut ça ça fait vachement moelleux
ses traits et au final bas ils
commençaient à 9h30 à 10h donc j'arrive
gpad antivol j'ai super mal aux pieds
pas celui-ci vous vous souvenez bien
dans l'épisode d'avant non mais
il faudra expliquer là à temps il est
débile de mecs bon écoutez ok je vois le
délire nous voilà du coup j ai dans le
qg le pied qui me brûle parce que ça et
j'ai pu le peau du cou sur l'orteil là
et du coup j'ai eu très mal au final je
me dis bon bah allez je rentre chez moi
donc je rentre et là je vous fais cette
petite vidéo mais c'était vraiment une
matinée de merde faut savoir qu'en plus
ce vélo est notamment très pourri je
sens chez moi je fais la descente
j'arrive en mahbod mme déraillé alors
que j'ai juste changé de plateaux au
québec et je perds quatre chaque merde
alors je change remet un bon plateau fin
je remets la chaîne ou alors il ya de la
mer sur les doigts et tout fait super
génial ça commence très bien cette
matinée et voila quoi fois y en avait
marre j'en avais trop marre j'en pouvais
plus ensuite j'irai avancé je re des
rails alors la laisse tomber j'étais
dans un étage taylor jamais marre j'en
pouvais plus et au final c'est là que je
rentre et que je vous fais cette [ __ ]
de vidéos sur des dalton et j'en ai ras
le cul des matinées de merde comme celle
que je viens de passer voilà bon ceci
étant des sceaux est pour les matinées
de merde voilà après les souhaits sur un
w 2 l'ac soissons matschiner pourri au
nom de dieu
alors je voulais aussi vous raconter
quelque chose d'important
ah oui à propos des vidéos sur
battlefield 3 comme je vous ai dit dans
la description là de la dernière c'est
assez important de vous dire que je suis
pas là pour faire enfin voilà peut-être
quand le jeu sera sorti officiellement
et que j'aurai une nouvelle config qui
permettra de filmer sans lag et plus
d'enregistrer ma voix en même temps plus
de me filme en même temps je peux vous
dire que ça prend des ressources tout ça
mine de rien donc quand j'aurai une
configuration qui permettra de faire
tout ça en même temps vous ferez des
live sur bf3 et ça le secret d'être
marrant mais en attendant je peux pas me
permettre d'en faire donc j'ai obligé de
faire des trucs assez sérieux bas de
toute façon étant donné que le jeu n'est
pas encore sorti
je fais une vidéo sur chaque classe donc
qui reste plus que deux classes donc
c'est la classe assaut la prochaine et
en fait j'ai confondu la classe support
dans bf3 ce n'est pas la classe assaut
la classe support dans bf3 en fait si
vous voulez c'est on a donc les grosses
armes de magic de bad company 2 là je
sais êtes un veinard
on a des grosses armes de meetic de bad
company 2 et on a eu les caisses de
munitions donc en gros c'est un mix
entre la classe magic et et asos de bad
company 2
pourquoi vous tapez vous a rien fait cet
homme comment elle rocks ça c'est de
l'art budget a mené mec
oui et donc du coup la classe assaut
c'est la classe medic la classe assaut
de battlefield 3 100 fait avec la somme
modique de bâle 3-2 bref à l'heure qu'il
est vous êtes sûrement tous en train de
comme ça sur la console voit donc je
pense que vous êtes au point sur sa
aucun problème mais je suis quand même
ses quatre petites vidéos pour ceux qui
n'ont pas la bêta qui ne s'impliquent
pas de console et qui veut en acheter la
nouvelle en même temps ou battlefield 3
quand on aura plus la bêta 10 octobre
vous pourrez tout de même les gens
pourront tourner même tombé sur ces
vidéos là il faut savoir s'ils
s'adressent pas c'est toujours à vous
les vidéos que je fais enfin si mais
voilà les vidéos sur des dalles sont des
tout voilà quand des gens qui me
connaissent pas tombe dessus ils font
mais c'est qui ce qui coup mais
qu'est-ce qui fait rigoler tout cas
marqué vidéo et une âme et chez bleu
rouge et donc je pense que je pense que
voilà vous aimerez vous vous êtes
vraiment si vous êtes abonné à cette
chaîne c'est parce que vous aimez
justement ses fans commenté ray donc
c'est pour ça que ma part ces quatre
vidéos sur boîte a fait 3 je vous
promets de faire vraiment que du fun et
au niveau du prochain défi ou [ __ ]
larmes de tarrier ça c'est le rire de
tazoult que j'ai fait un petit bisou à
tester un ami vent il fait bien trippé
sur skype il ya vraiment serré à l'art
et les traumas enfin bon ok pas ça alors
on va tout réparer parce qu'on est un
peu des riches
ouais enfin on y est plutôt et doullens
cours alors attendez il va falloir que
j'ai en mêle des objets dans ma truc si
je trouve comment ouais comme tu te
calmes ok tu fais pas le fou d'accord je
te pète un trou ok on va prendre ça
3000 xp voire même la difficulté de la
mission je m'en fous le sco alors que
faut-il faire
ouais c'est de sortir pour qui l'
indicateur en tout cas je sois vraiment
mes vidéos continue de vous plaire ah
oui aussi je voulu expliquer pour cette
petite intro bon pour ceux que l'ont pas
lu la description
pourquoi y'a plus rien qui s'affiche sur
la carte faudra m'expliquer quand même
en fait je m'étais juste taper une
petite barre avec un avis du lycée où on
est allé aux toilettes pour boire on a
vu que kkr ont marqué sur une pincée m'a
dit va regarder comme ça et ça voulait
dire fais pas trop avec ça et du coup on
a fait une intro plutôt pourri mais
c'est pas grave on s'est bien marré moi
j'espère que ça vous aura plu quand même
mais bon c'est une intro complètement
millions écoutez c'est ce qui fait que
je suis ce que je suis fini
ça c'était beau ça c'est ce qui fait ce
qui fait non je sais mais puisque j'ai
dit c'est ce qui fait ce qui fait ce que
je suis pour quelque chose du genre
enfin bref en tout cas c'était assez
violent effort
alors y at il des quêtes affaires bas
ici ou alors on va aller sauvagement tué
du zombie comme tu es beau bonjour ag où
ils effeuillent c'est tout qu'est-ce
complétait d'accord ce n'est pas que
j'étais tellement difficulty hard torche
mode au ca va etre genre l'homme torche
ou non je pense pas ou alors jouer un
petit club performant d'uranium
j'ai été clair la tête pétiton béique
rencontrant marrant non
bon je sais pas on va bien voir salut à
toi mon ami que veux-tu difficulty a
hammer à 8 ya aussi je vais faire ce que
m'avaient tous conseillé de faire mettez
un point spécial pour les capacités ça
doit être dans ce qu'il
je sais pas aussi mais c'est pas oui je
vais me le donner en pleine vidéo c'est
génial c'est pas merde façon j'ai pas de
points mais je sais pas vous m'avez dit
qu'il y avait un skin spécial genre
furet à ça doit être ça voilà ok ça doit
être ça bref je mets dedans ça ok
d'accord ça marche ça marche nos
problèmes les amis alors attendez je
vais juste mettre des armes un peu mieux
ça c'est le bruit dans ce crunch est
passée d'un trou qui l'ont vue sonore
en tout cas il est bien pourri mais
vraiment il est à chier et je dis pas ça
pour faire genre nuls
c'est juste nul en bref allez go
j'arrête de parler pour rien dire ce que
je sais la majorité de mes vidéos vous
me verrez donc je sais pas vraiment ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire pour le moment
il faut peut-être comprennent la voiture
and on voit là ok c'est là bas j'arrive
là jamais plaint un brin là ça va tuer
des zombies siècle les amis regardez non
mais attendez
ah oui alors que vous m'avez dit que
c'était en fait des assassins c'est pas
des gorilles à écouter on va essayer de
pas lui je prends une mourir comment ça
rox a regardé je les touche hot et je
crains qu'ils feed c'est trop bien ces
termes d'un mets toi fais pas la maline
ok alors toi toi tu vas juste aller les
gars j'ai de la ok + attend c'est un
autre gorille non non il n'en est pas là
il est tout le salut ouais c'est un
walker mais ça c'est donc un assassin
attendez on va on va voir on va
s'approcher de lui on va sonner voir ok
y'a des gens alors au niveau de vos
techniques pour les tuer merci vous
m'avez m'a fait bien informés alors ah
[ __ ] haut
non mais c'est pas possible d'être aussi
chiant que ça quoi j'entendais pas aux
longues étapes aux messieurs dames
ça s'appelle juliette apens bref on
m'avait dit que c'était pas possible de
mais qu'est ce que je dois faire mais
calme toi
calme-toi calme-toi mon ami c'est bon
stop arrête
bon ok je sais pas ce qu'il faut que je
fasse avec cette foutue pièce je vais
essayer d'aller à sa me suis un geek g -
[ __ ] c'est pas possible quoi ils sont
vraiment chiant oh là là incroyable bond
et où je vais la fac les amis je ne
comprends absolument rien qui ait des
broussailles chevaux si je passe dedans
je me faire démonter par une horde de
zombies affamés
ok y'a personne bon que dois-je faire
don de dieu je ne sais point où dois-je
aller a eu l'accord de suivre les petits
chemins en fait voilà en plus j'ai pas
pour rien dire c'est affolant un bref
wahaha oh là là mais quel bande de
mais c'est incroyable les amis en tout
cas je suis pas content de cette foutue
matinée et j'espère que ces petites
vidéos sur bf3 que je prends même pas
mal de temps à faire vous auront plus il
reste encore deux à faire j'espère que
ça vaudra le coup que je voulais face en
tout cas j'espère que ma chaîne vous
plaît toujours autant que je ne vous
déçoit tu peux pas en tout cas je prends
je trouve pas que je crois la bourse et
ou quoi d'ailleurs le principe de ma
chaîne sait on est à l'aise et cool ça y
est le gros fanboy des pzk non non c'est
juste de ne pas se prendre la tête
au niveau du défi à kenge z on va
sûrement faire un samedi donc j'espère
que ça vous plaira on pourra en fait si
vous voulez bon je vais vous dire on
voulait faire un défi mots je sais pas
si je vous le dis aux voix non je vous
le dis pas je vous laisse la surprise
c'est mieux de passer on a quelques-uns
d'entre eux vocation courant on avait
donné un indice dans un live ou en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que on a besoin
d'un objet cet objet c'est un ami qui
doit nous donner et en fait je peux pas
voilà on va je vais juste vous dire ça
je pense que ça raccourcira bien des
choses mais [ __ ] mais je fais rien là
c'est affreux je dois prendre des
caisses pour les ramener chez paou bon
ok j'entends monsieur boum boum quoi le
gars cheikh mbacké calpella gâchette
train mais sans rien oui donc je disais
on va on va vous faire un truc que je
sais pas trop ce qu'on va faire encore
j'ai une petite idée derrière la tête
mais ça va servir tout autour de moi
donc faudrait éviter
voilà faudrait mettre des bâches et où
bref c'est compliqué en tout cas je vais
essayer de vous faire ça ce soir ou
alors demain alors qu'il faut que j'aime
être là en fait
adacore messieurs dames désormais je
comprends tout je comprends tout je sais
pas trop à quoi ça sert mais écoutez
faut qu'il mette la balle et matelas
le gorille enfin le bois et le ninja
pardon basse et la bafa bref je disais
oui donc on va essayer mais je vous
promets que on va peut-être réussir à
faire le truc qu'on voulait faire à la
base avec angie z ça dépend d'un ami
s'il peut nous prêter l'instrument ou
pas et je peux vous dire que franchement
si on y arrive ce sera les meilleurs
défis que vous aurez jamais vue est
vraiment franchement ça vous fera rien
mais rire aux éclats avec vous dans
toute blanche comme sagna à l'ordinateur
ça sera franchement drôle d et il y en a
aussi qui m'ont dit que leurs parents
les prenait pour des fous parce qu'il
rigolait comme des terres est devant
leurs ordis devant les défis ça va bien
faire je me suis dis bah écoutez
propofol en tout cas toi tu vas pas me
fait longtemps 1
voilà mais franchement j'espère vraiment
que ces défis vous plaît j'espère
j'espère j'espère en tout cas je pense
que c'est probablement le meilleur
concept de ma chaîne les défis de
squeeze et mg zr je vais rajouter
bientôt là parce que ça se fait pas il
est tout le temps avec moi et c'est lui
un peu qu'ils créent l'ambiance du truc
parce que c'est pas marrant de faire un
défi tout seul je serai là tout seul à
mettre des termes encore plus marrant
non franchement ça absolument aucun sens
donc je je je fais tu ferais toujours ce
défi avec lui et peut-être kenge êtes
d'ailleurs va se créer une chaîne
youtube ses passions mais va peut-être
se créer une chaîne youtube donc écouter
ça serait franchement marrant dès qu'il
est en hd pvr il va s'ancrer wind et
franchement ça serait ça serait vraiment
marrant vraiment vraiment voir enfin bon
je voulais aussi vous parler de la
blague international des profs les amis
alors ça vous est forcément arrivé
oui toi qui regarde cette vidéo
forcément un prof tu as déjà fait cette
blague alors tu es en cours je sais pas
apte à un moment où tu es d'istres et
moi en l'occurrence j'étais à souhait il
ya un seuil à deux rangées bientôt
ranger la wax est en vue il a dérangé
locaux d'orange et là ils dérangent et
la moitié dans les dangers du milieu
j'étais là comme ça tu c'est chiant
c'est un compte français
je regarde ma droite comme ça je fais
aux comores en oiseau est en fait il y
avait un bout de lampadaires qui dépasse
et je me demandais ce que c'était à bout
d'un mois j'ai compris que c'est un
boulot pas d'heure donc j'étais comme ça
elle se met à écrire au tableau donc moi
j'attends qu'elle finisse écrire parce
qu'ils nous ont aidés à son bras qui
cache c'est super chiant mais dire à
l'aiea car ils les chiens ciel là donc
elle fini d'écrire et elle surtout ne
fera même pas fini surtout elle fait
débat alors tu écris pas un yatch rien
dr dalmat ton carnet je lui fais pas
écouter madame j'attendais vous finissez
d'écrire pour pour pompon pour écrire
voilà après que je m'en fous tu me
donnes ton carnet et là forcément faux
comme moi vous avez déjà répondu un prof
l'ours qui vous a demandé votre carnet
bas jury au feu et là forcément
l'apprend vous a répondu
elle bat justement c'est ça le problème
et ça c'est la blague international des
profs la fenêtre de ma chambre est
ouvert tout le monde tout le quartier a
dû entendre cette blague et a dû rigoler
on se regarde non mais vraiment quoi
c'est la blague la plus pittoresque que
j'ai entendu de ma vie quoi mais
justement chéchia le problème en
attentant bull met une claque guerre
n'avait ferme ta bouche quoi enfin
cesser c'est pas marrant ce n'était pas
marrant tu fais chier tout le monde
rentre chez toi un tel que vous fassiez
voilà enfin vous enfin bon voilà cette
vidéo touche à sa fin c'était très court
c'était pas content du tout c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment je sors pas mal de
vidéos donc je le réserve des trucs à
dire pour les prochaines vidéos
c'étaient les péripéties de squeeze et
ya une vidéo bonus dans la description
donc si vous êtes fidèle à moi et que
vous regardez mes vidéos jusqu'à la fin
vous pourrez donc voir cette vidéo bonus
et je peux vous dire tu sais une vidéo
bonus très très bizarre très étrange et
et au toit aux toilettes
enfin si j'étais au lycée camille sée
djiba c'est après avoir fait un truc
complètement bidon et après il m'a dit
wave y ont fait des vidéos dans le lycée
ledoux donc chez vas-y est en fait il ya
des toilettes donc dehors donc là c'est
ultra fréquenté au rez-de-chaussée donc
dans l'établissement ça c'est quand même
pas mal fréquenté première et hachez les
profs et deuxième étages ses toilettes
sur craig perche elle n'y va jamais nous
cogner à aller on a inspecté ses
toilettes
et franchement c'est taper une grosse
baffe en quoi qu'il en soit je conçois
très bien que 90% d'entre vous n'auront
pas cette vidéo mais c'était un petit
délire qu'on a fait avec mon ami donc je
pense que j'espère en tout cas que y'en
aura pas mal qui rigoleront devant
c'était complètement con c'était les
découvertes des toilettes secrète avec
le guide luc chabasse qui s'appelle
lucas comme moi et j'espère que ça vous
plaira le lien dans la description
j'afficherai une annotation maintenant à
sur la vidéo
en tout cas j'espère cette petite vidéo
vous aura plu on se retrouve très
prochainement pour un défi de squeeze ou
alors avec la classe assaut dans
battlefield 3 ciao tout le monde bat et
portez vous bien je vais mal fait portez
vous bien